[Music]  [Applause]  why would i betray you we all have our  secrets  we just didn't get to yours yet  the world is arming faster than we can  respond  where's double 07.  i need a favor brother you're the only  one i trust for this  the world's moved on commander bond you  were double o two years  so stay in your lane you get in my way i  will put a bullet in your knee  [Music]  the one that works i thought you two  would get along  lame bond  james bond  so you're not dead look you i've missed  you  it's the most valuable asset this  country has if you feel yourself losing  control i'm not going to lose  patrol  james  you gave up everything for her  when her secret finds its way out  it'll be the death of him  what is it you don't know what this is  james  bond  license to kill  history of violence  i could be speaking to my own reflection  only your skills die with your body  mine will survive long after i'm gone  history isn't kind to men who play god  so  [Music]  [Music]  you